lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
analizar dos escenarios en donde un
objeto tiene movimiento circular
uniforme es decir sigue una trayectoria
circular con una velocidad constante lo
que queremos hacer es pensar en por qué
se mantiene en dicha trayectoria
circular qué fuerza centrípeta evita que
el objeto salga disparado en línea recta
en este primer escenario tenemos una
rueda atada con una cuerda que a su vez
está atada a un clavo que se encuentra
en el centro de esta mesa esta rueda se
mueve en esta trayectoria circular con
una rapidez constante pausa en el vídeo
y traten de pensar en todas las fuerzas
que están actuando sobre esta rueda y
cuáles fuerzas o combinaciones de
fuerzas están actuando como la fuerza
centrípeta que mantiene a esta rueda en
el movimiento circular
resolvamos estos juntos tenemos dos
fuerzas que hacen que la rueda se
mantenga en esta trayectoria circular
tenemos la fuerza de gravedad suponiendo
que todo esto se encuentra en un planeta
denotamos su magnitud con la letra
mayúscula efe subíndice head y esta
flecha indica su dirección la razón por
la que la rueda no acelera hacia abajo
es porque la mesa ejerce una fuerza
sobre la rueda es la fuerza normal que
contrarresta a la fuerza de gravedad
esta es la fuerza normal y tienen la
misma magnitud que la fuerza de gravedad
pero va en dirección opuesta que otras
fuerzas están aquí pueden imaginar que
si no estuviera esta cuerda atada a la
rueda ésta saldría disparada en línea
recta y caería de la mesa por lo que la
cuerda ejerce cierta fuerza hacia
adentro lo que hace que la rueda se
mueva de forma circular la fuerza en la
cuerda que jala la rueda es la fuerza de
tensión y denotamos su magnitud como efe
subíndice t
en esta situación esta es la fuerza que
va hacia adentro esta es la fuerza
centrípeta la magnitud de la fuerza
atención es igual a la fuerza centrípeta
en este caso los vectores también son
iguales la atención en esta cuerda es la
fuerza centrípeta lo que permite que la
rueda siga en trayectoria circular
veamos otro ejemplo aquí tenemos una
configuración similar aunque tiene más
dimensiones en este ejemplo clásico de
física tenemos una cuerda atada al techo
y la cuerda tiene atada una pelota o
péndulo del otro lado la pelota se mueve
en una trayectoria circular con una
velocidad constante aquí está el centro
del círculo pausa en el vídeo y traten
de encontrar todas las fuerzas que
actúan sobre esta pelota aquí no
contemplamos la resistencia al aire pues
suponemos que esto se encuentra en el
vacío cuál de esas fuerzas actúa como la
fuerza centrípeta como en el ejemplo
anterior aquí tenemos una fuerza de
gravedad que es este vector de magnitud
f subíndice g y también tenemos la
cuerda que sostiene la pelota aquí
tenemos una fuerza que jala este vector
es la fuerza de tensión ft pero que
contrarresta a la gravedad y que
mantiene el movimiento circular de la
pelota
situación podemos ver los diferentes
componentes de la fuerza de tensión la
cual vemos tiene un ángulo descomponemos
este vector en su componente vertical
lucía así y lo denominamos efe subíndice
t y esta es la magnitud del componente y
de la fuerza de atención esto es lo que
contrarresta la fuerza de gravedad evita
que la pelota acelere hacia abajo
el componente x de la fuerza de tensión
lo dibujamos así y lo denominamos efe
subíndice de x es la magnitud del
componente x de esta fuerza y esto es la
fuerza centrípeta en esta situación el
componente de la atención en la
dirección x que indicamos como vector es
la fuerza centrípeta lo que hace que la
pelota siga una trayectoria circular
nos vemos en otro vídeo